hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar and power electrophysiology data
analysis with new clamps at 11 advanced
event detection i am michelle ashton of
labyrinth and I'll be your moderator for
today's event today's educational web
seminar is presented by labyrinth and
brought to you by molecular devices to
learn more about our sponsor please
visit www.opm.gov/life to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
and anytime you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send so answer as many questions as you
have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation click on the
support tab found at the top-right of
the presentation window or report your
problems by clicking on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on a
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credit
now at today's speaker dr. Gillian
technical support application scientist
at molecular devices for a complete
biography on our speaker please visit
the loud if you tab at the top of your
screen dr. Graham you may now begin your
presentation
thank you for presenting Michelle for
the introduction hello everyone thank
you for attending the webinar I've been
working with molecular devices for four
years and talked and emails with a lot
of you guys
it's my pressure here to be here today
to introduce our new transit 11 in 2018
we have been developing and rolling out
our new peak ramp software throughout
the years we have been getting requests
for our end-users about how to improve
our software to make the acquisition and
data analysis easier for
electrophysiologist we would like to
take this opportunity to thank you all
for the invaluable inputs and suggestion
so here it comes the new T camp 11
software we will have a series of
webinars to cover the new functions in
context and clamp it this is our first
webinar for the P clamp 11 today we will
cover part of the new functions in
transit 11
this is today's agenda first I will give
an overview for P camp 11 and then I
will mainly focus on the event detection
function and I will demo examples for
template search population spike search
and action potential search unlike the
previous version of P camp piquant 11
comes with standard version and advanced
version the difference is that we see
camp 11 advanced version you will have
access to our newly developed clamp fit
11 advanced version if you order P clamp
11 standard version you will receive a
black dongle for using clamp acts 10
feet 11 standard version is free and you
can download and install it and use it
on any computers if you oddity camp 11
advanced version you will receive two
dongles the black dongle for using camp
ax and the wide angle for using transit
advanced version up for the software
compatibility our software is backward
compatible which means data acquired
from previous version of plank camp acts
such as camp acts 9 and 10 can be
analyzed with transit 11 software we do
also sell creme fit 11 advanced version
alone if you hesitate about upgrading
the contacts right now but you really
like the new features will can fit 11
you can purchase the transit 11 advanced
version alone
close fit adverse version comes with new
exclusive features including batch
analysis automated population spike
search and action potential search as
you can see that if you don't plug in
the wide angle these features are grayed
out and you cannot use it once you plug
in the wide angle the advanced feature
will be active so today we will focus on
some of the new features of 10 feet 11
batch analysis is the newly developed
function in transit 11 advanced version
it's located at analysis batch analysis
we are not going to cover the function
today but we sure will do another
webinar on this topic later
you
is how it looks for can fit 11 transit
11 looks very similar to our previous
version of cramped once you open the
transit you will see several windows the
trees recorded in the contacts is open
in the main window and the results
result window present the analysis
results the logbook window keeps track
of everything that has been done in the
transit software the first improvement
we have made to both our transcripts
standard and advanced version is that we
increase the search ability by
increasing the pairs of cursors for 2050
11 you are able to use 25 pairs of
cursors compared to nine pairs of
cursors in classic 10 so let's do a demo
on how to bring out all the cursors and
use them
when you open the data in the main
window right-click the mouse and go to
the properties at the bottom of the
window you can see the cursor options so
it allows you to bring up to 25 pairs of
cursors so today let's bring our five
pairs of cursors
and we are going to use the bring Kurtis
to show all the curses
we were used crystalline cursor to for
base for baseline and the rest for pairs
for measuring the peaks
you
you
you
after we layout the cursors let's go to
analysis statistics so if we look at the
data these are negative going peak and
we will use the mean level between
cursor one in the cursor to as the
baseline we can have up to four search
region
you
the first search reading will be between
cruiser three and kurtal for
the second search region will be between
cursor five and cursor six
the third search region will be between
cursor seven and curse for eight
and the fourth search region will be
between Kurt's online cursor ten
so for each search aging you can specify
the parameters that you want to
calculate so for here we are going to
calculate the peak amplitude and time of
PEEP
you
now we have set up everything and click
OK
now go to the result sheet you can see
that four peaks and the fourth high more
peaks has been calculated for us this
features significantly increased the
analysis ability and allows you to
gather data in one search
you
next we will take a look at the template
search Henry search is not a new
function but I found that it is a little
bit tricky for a lot of users to make a
good template and to balance between the
template match threshold first positive
without enforced negative result can't
research is best for spontaneous
synaptic event since these events are
normally small in signal-to-noise ratio
is not the greatest and it is hard to
use the threshold search to locate the
event to my experience the key to a
successful attempt a search would be to
make representative templates that could
represent your data we will talk about
how to make good templates
during the demo the other important
factor is to find an appropriate
template match threshold templates match
thresholds value determines the degree
of similarity and event must have to the
template to be found in the search the
higher the value the more similar event
needs to be in order to be found while a
lower value increases the chance of
fourth quality
the disk value for helping fund to
provide a good balance we will see how
this number will affect the search
result in demo
you
so let's move on to the demo
you
you
this is our data we can see that it is a
spontaneous EPS C recording so first
let's make some template let's go to the
event detection create template
you
let's bring out our cursor one cursor to
you
we can add this first event once we add
it the event will show up in a template
window
once you add the first event the cursors
get locked making sure that each one of
the event is of the same length and the
system will automatically search for the
next event for us sometimes the
automatic search is not ideal you can
also do manual search so we will just
pull and add the events that we think is
more appropriate
once you find the next event I'll I it
with the template and then add it
you
a light and add it
after adding several events we can save
this as a template and use it for the
template search for this particular data
I have I've already pre made a template
so let's try it and do the tempeh search
you
go to event detection template search
so we can see this is a positive going
event we will load the template
you
this vulnerable amplitude template click
box by selecting this option meaning
that the peak amplitude is included as a
matching criteria in the detection of
event it helps you to eliminate a noise
so we will click this click box and next
we will use the cursor to include the
whole event
we will set the baseline in analysis
window
you
we will start from the default values
template match threshold f4 and let's
read
Oh
we can see that we missed several events
which is not very ideal the number of
events is 24 you can find it here number
of events in viewer so we want to
decrease the template match threshold
and try it again
you
let's do this again using the template
match threshold s3 click OK and run we
are still missing this event we found
two more than so let's try the crease
the threshold again
you
so this time we will use templates match
threshold to
we can see that although we have
increased the number of events but we
started to pick up false positive result
you can see the noises here getting
picked up so I don't think 2 is a good
idea if we take a closer look at the
events that we are missing here
you
and compare it with our template
we can see that the template has a much
faster right time while the ones that we
are missing has much slower writing time
so in this particular data the right
time of these events are very different
so we are missing the world that we
slower right time what we can do here is
to make another template with the slower
right time and create another search
category to using the template with the
slower right time and search and again
with two template
so here
first we are going to make a new
template
and at this time we will focus on the
ones that have slower right time let's
bring out our cursor one cursor to
and we will look for this event with
slower rise time
you
we can add it to the template
you
I like it add it to the template
you
lie add it to the template by adding
several of these events we can save it
as a secondary template and we will do
it with two templates
so let's go to event detection temp
research
you
we will keep the category one as it is
and increase the template match
threshold to 3 because 2 gives us 4th
positive result
now we are going to add another category
card over to
template with slower right time
you
again we are going to check the variable
amplitude template click box to avoid
the noise
use the cursor to include the whole
event set the baseline in analysis
window set the template match threshold
to 3
and cook okay
now let's go
at this time you can see that it almost
picks up every event and the number of
events has increased to 40 at this point
if you open the result sheet you can see
all the parameters get calculated for
each event this has picked up more than
95% of the event we think it's a very
successful template search
you
you
you
you
next we will talk about action potential
search in previous versions of the pee
camp we are using threshold search to
measure the parameters of action
potential in P camp 11 this all new
automated action potential search makes
the action potential analysis much
easier within one search you can get all
the parameters here I will share some
experience in making successful action
potential search for action potential
search it's very important that you set
up the correct baseline if the baseline
is not straight you need to straight
head before doing the event searching
when measuring the right time and decay
time the software uses the peak value
baseline value and the anti peak value
to calculate the percentage change so
that brings it to our second
point when you are doing the search
making sure that you capture the whole
event from the baseline to the peak to
hide hospitalization and then back to
the baseline otherwise without these
numbers the measurement are either
missing or not correct this is the main
complaint I got for doing the event
detection you will need to take a look
at your data and adjust the pre trigger
and post trigger time to capture the
whole event we will discuss this further
in a demo so now let's move on to the
demo
you
you
you
this is cardiac action potential cardiac
action potential is very different from
neuronal action potential in the shape
we can see that the duration is much
longer we want to include the whole
event from the initial depolarization to
the recovery to the baseline we first
use the cursor to measure the start of
the action potential to the peak so we
will use cursor when the cursor to
you
this Delta value tells us between cursor
and the cursor - it's about nine
milliseconds so if we put 20
milliseconds in the pre trigger duration
we should be open we should be able to
capture the pre trigger and if we
measure from the peak to the recovery to
the baseline
if Delta value tells us it's about 500
milliseconds so if we put 600 600
milliseconds we should be able to
capture the hosts trigger duration
[Music]
for cardiac action potential action
potential 90% is a very important
parameter with this all new action
potential search function this parameter
gets calculated automatically so let's
set up the action potential search let's
go to event detection
action potential search so first we will
go we will set up the baseline
and the trigger
we will put 20 milliseconds to the pre
triggered duration and we will put 600
milliseconds to the post triggered
duration and we can measure amplitude
area to action potential duration
different numbers for the action
potential duration right time decay time
right slow the case low threshold
potential maximum right slope and
maximum decay slope
let's click OK and right
we can see that in the results sheet all
the numbers getting calculated for us
you
if we look at the Event Viewer window we
can see that the whole action potential
get captured in this event viewer window
but if we look at here the base I starts
at zero if you go to the option and
unclick the ally events as zero now we
can see the real baseline
I want to show you if we don't set this
up correctly what will happen we will
run this again this time we are not
going to set up for the pre triggered
duration and post triggered duration
we will read
we can see that in the Event Viewer
window
we only capture a part of the event the
part that first crosses the threshold
and the end when the event crossed the
threshold again if we look at the
results only entries only peak amplitude
is getting calculated all the other
numbers cannot be calculated cause the
event is not intact therefore it is very
important to make sure that you set up
the correct pre trigger time and post
your time to capture the whole event
you
next we are going to do a demo for a
evoked action potential data let's take
a look at the data
you
this is very typical regard recording
and not normally used to find out the
real base current and also calculate the
firing frequency as each current
injection level for this kind of data
normally we don't calculate the kinetics
profile including rise time right-hand
slope the K time and decay time flow
since the real baseline is not clear we
are more interested in peak to peak time
in the cumulative min frequency for each
sweep so let's run our action potential
search on this data go to event
detection action potential search
again we are going to set up the
baseline and the trigger
you
these we don't really care about the
current kinetics and we only need to
include a peak this is a fast neuronal
action potential I will put three
milliseconds for the pre peak pre
tribulation and five milliseconds for
the post triggered duration and we don't
care about the APD numbers the right
time decay hi we're more interested in
peak to peak time peak to peak frequency
cumulative link frequency change in
amplitude per peak okay let's run
we can see that in the day in the
results it has calculated for us
how many action potentials are in each
trace they also calculate for us what is
the peak to peak frequency and the
cumulative link frequency in that trace
this is very useful feature for this
type of data
you
you
next we will talk about the population
spike analysis population spikes are
electric signals that are generated by
the synchronized flowering of the groups
of closely spaced neurons that receive
synaptic inputs simultaneously normally
the parameters we are interested in the
population spike our amplitude coastline
and area when doing the analysis first
we make a rich tangent line and and then
we make a perpendicular line to this
line and connect it with the peak value
this is the amplitude for the population
spike and it's called the amplitude also
we are interested in the coastline
cosine is the summation of
point-to-point amplitude over the event
person
from rich - rich but not including this
line and the area is the event
calculated between this line and the
event profile
as you can see these parameters are hard
to calculate using conventional method
so here I'm going to show you the beauty
population spike search from P camp 11
and let's move on to the demo
you
you
this is a very typical population spike
data as you can see at the beginning we
see a huge the Malaysian artifact this
is the demolition for your stimulator
the initial still epsp is generated from
area distant from the focal area
followed by that we can see two
relatively large epsp
fueled potential generated by groups of
Europe these are our area of interest to
analyze this data let's go to event
detection
population spikes search
this is the negative going peak and we
will use crystal one cursor to to
include the whole event
you
next we are going to set up the baseline
the base is at a wrong zero
and we will use the upper and the lower
bomb line to include the whole man
you
next we will use Christmas tree and
cursor for to ignore to reading so first
we are going to ignore the initial field
epsp from the distant area
setup cursor 3 and cursor full
we click ignore reaching one
and edit next we are going to ignore the
region after the second field EPS in a
field EP SP
you
you
you
ignore region 2 and edit
we can find to it by setting the minimum
event amplitude at 0.2 and the minimal
event duration is 0.2 milliseconds
now let's take a look at the
measurements we want so in the
measurement we will choose the ones that
we are interested including latency the
amplitude
area half width and coastline
you
and click ok and now we can write
you
let's take a look at the individual
event we can see that the software draw
the line nice thing for us and in the
result sheet
a the amplitude latency half with area
and the coastline are all calculated
applause if we add these trip
we can see that in a second trip this is
not her event
so one flexibility you have in the
population spike search is that even
after you finish the analysis you can
modify and delete the event that you
don't want here's how you can do it in
the result sheet highlight this event
and go to this triangular tool
process selection and click change state
and reject this event
once you reject it it will be deleted
from the result sheet
you
you
but we can see this data is a very clean
data in reality when the data is messy
the line could be wrong therefore in the
menu search mode we have provided a more
flexible way for the user to find
through the life so let's take this
sweep as an example
we need to run population spike search
again with the same parameters
before we accept them
result let's click this pencil to
now you can find to this line and also
the ridge line
once you are satisfied with the life
except to the event
the numbers will show up in the results
it
so this is what you can do with the
population spike search hope this is a
useful tool to help you with your
population spike analysis this is
everything that we have for today's
webinar I like to thank you again for
participating the webinar and let's move
on to the question and answer part
thank you doctor contagion we will now
start the Q&A portion
yikes
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
to answer as many questions as we have
time for okay our first question is
you
you
I used to use threshold search to
analyze action potentials now the newer
version has action potential search what
is the difference between threshold
search and action potential search and
which one is the best way to analyze
action potential
so such whole search provides a rough
way of analyzing the action potential
data you can definitely use it but the
thing is it's not as smart as action
potential search action potential search
is more suitable and much easier to use
than the search whole search and also it
provides a lot of parameters which is
more meaningful for action potential
nurses for example for the cardiac
action potential it calculates the
action potential duration 90 diversity
for you but it doesn't it doesn't do
that in the threshold search and for the
neuronal action potential the firing
frequency are calculated automatically
for you so for analyzing the action
potential I would say automated action
potential search is far better than the
search whole search while search whole
search itself is not only just for
action potential analysis it can be used
for other type of data for example if
you have a good signal to ratio you can
use it to analyze the Evoque epsp and
eps see yeah but for action financial
analysis I would definitely recommend
the action potential search
great thank you okay next question how
do you calculate the threshold in action
potential search and so for these you
can actually find it in the help so
after you click the action potential
search at the bottom go to the help it
will guide you to well most of these
definitions are so for the threshold
potential we have a definition that it's
the amplitude at which the action
potential is initiated in an approach in
approximately of this position is fine
it's found by finding the intersection
of the rising phase of action potential
and the slope leading up to its
initiation step subsequently a
three-point tangent slope vector is used
to find the position in the initial
region where the slope is at or above 10
millivolts per millisecond
Thank You dr. Han do you have any final
comments for our audience before we
close el
um nope why I would like this Baker go
ahead sorry I would like to thank
everyone for attending the webinar we
would like to thank you for your time
today and for your important research we
would also like to thank lab roots and
our sponsor molecular devices for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go I'd love to thank the
audience for joining us today
questions we did not have time for today
in those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed via to fear the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration this webcast can be
viewed on-demand lab or alert via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's event until next time bye